[Music]
ladies are extraordinarily beautiful
you're very sexy and and then yes some
of that was for me but but the men have
been getting some attention you you know
for being sexy you've been you've been
in People's Sexiest guy issue right well
my cat my cat was I got the high but I
really want to talk to Stephen about
this photo that that I saw that really
[Applause]
what are you doing there are you
exhausting your own head that this is
not accurate this sexy thing is not it
doesn't make sense
it's a weird it's a weird situation to
be asked to be in that thing because
that's not me and I have actually
something that shows everyone who I
really am this is the core of Who I am I
have brought a picture that's
glasses look at the crown look at the
windbreaker that gene the jeans start
here is that as you are you wearing a
fanny pack oh yeah oh yeah why wouldn't
I be wearing a fine and then the hands
it's this it's this these guys yeah it's
there you work where are you in that
coat oh I've haven't medieval times and
I think I'm ha ha ha ha ha ok duh
that's all you had to say that's all you
had to say to get out of the sexy issue
was I was at medieval times you didn't
need anything else